[Música]
hola bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión de
reporteros en france 24 como siempre un
gusto acompañarlos desde hace tres meses
un territorio en medio de las aguas
turquesas del mediterráneo oriental está
en el ojo de un ciclón geopolítico
kastelorizo un islote griego de nueve
kilómetros cuadrados en el que viven
unos 200 habitantes en un pueblo en la
montaña muy muy lejos de atenas su
posición geográfica a 130 kilómetros al
sudeste de la isla de rodas la isla
griega más cercana a escasos 2
kilómetros de la costa de anatolia
kastelorizo ofrece a grecia una
gigantesca zona económica exclusiva en
casi toda la costa mediterránea de
turquía país que lo ve como una
injusticia tras la escalada de las
tensiones del verano que hizo que
francia desplegará varios buques
militares junto con la marina griega
turquía envió su buque de exploración
hace dos semanas para buscar gas en la
costa sur de la isla una zona que grecia
reivindica como su plataforma
contín
cómo viven el estar entre dos fuegos los
habitantes de esta isla tan conocida en
la historia y cómo perciben el conflicto
que se despliega frente a sus ventanas
veamos el reportaje
i
[Música]
eran las siete y diez de la mañana yo
estaba justo ahí llenando el tanque de
mi barco
esta frase es capitán de un taxi barco
hace treinta años que trabaja alrededor
de la isla y un dron que volaba muy bajo
justo ahí pero stabros nunca había visto
o más bien escuchado algo así y del
rosalía música era el himno turco una
noticia que salió de la televisión
griega
se necesitan los más elegidos en la
autogestión que palito de pelo tipo
gratis trate tanto el examen o cata poco
sexy ni tanto micro atlético ni te
quitan shirín state era provocar a
ofrecer aporta negaba ladrón o políticos
étnicos en los aporten arte y otro pelo
como todos los habitantes de la isla
está bruce quedó atónito pero esto era
sólo el comienzo
unos minutos después de la alcaldía
inmediatamente ordenó que se pintara la
pared de rojo los soldados vinieron y lo
hicieron de inmediato
ellos me sorprendió mucho es nuestra
bandera nuestro orgullo es terrible
la foto propio y mientras vista está
dedicado para mí
cuidado bien el ejército no pueden
grabar
[Música]
hay turbulencias en las aguas turquesas
del mediterráneo oriental
durante los últimos tres meses los
ruidos de los motores de las fragatas
militares aviones de combate y el eco
submarino de la exploración sísmica han
estado perturbando la tranquilidad de la
isla más remota de grecia
[Música]
el tono en cuanto a sus aguas
potencialmente ricas en gas sube
[Música]
y ustedes el pueblo griego acepta lo que
podría pasarles por culpa de sus
codiciosos e incompetentes líderes
si somos trastornado la unión europea ha
sido muy clara en cuanto a las
consecuencias en turquía sigue con este
comportamiento agresivo en turquía son
el creus xy perform kastelorizo
es una isla simbólica a ambos lados del
estrecho brazo del mar egeo los
ministros y oficiales del ejército se
enfrentan a pesar de sus habitantes la
isla se ve erigida como un nuevo puesto
de avanzada de grecia en la unión
europea frente a las ambiciones turcas
en el mediterráneo
sin embargo en la isla todo parece estar
muy tranquilo incluso demasiado
tranquilo para el gusto de los locales
la mayoría de los cuales dependen del
turismo
[Música]
como mariah la persona más vieja de la
isla y su hijo yorgos o que manejan la
taberna al azar aquí en el puerto entre
el hobby de la crisis política
los turistas se fueron y la familia
perdió el 60% de sus ingresos de la
temporada
y la cobertura mediática de las
tensiones no ha ayudado no lo voy a
creer cuando prendí el televisor y vi a
los periodistas aquí haciendo reportajes
de guerra
dm y hablé con ellos habían estado
kosovo líbano estás kastelorizo
cosmopolita y europea y era picante
camineras todos aquí se niegan a ver su
isla transformada en una línea de frente
los turcos son vecinos y arbórea
solíamos ir a las fiestas de los turcos
y ellos solían venir aquí a celebrar la
pascua con nosotros lo que mi mamá está
diciendo es que los turcos de enfrente
los capitanes de los barcos turcos todos
aquellos con los que trabajamos
habitualmente nos llaman a menudo nos
piden noticias nos llevamos muy bien
y hay un chico y una chica ya incluso se
casaron
una vez
un matrimonio mixto el único que
recuerda maría simboliza para todos la
esperanza en estos tiempos difíciles
si coses griega de kastelórizo we cool
es turca de casi se enamoraron se
casaron en 2012 y son padres de un
pequeño de tres años su restaurante está
ubicado en la pequeña isla de saint
george entre sus dos ciudades de origen
que se siente estar en el medio
es una sensación extraña porque mi
esposa desde casa y con el convite
estamos bloqueados en este lado en el
poli pero el guardia de cervera para su
familia extrañas
no podemos visitarlos así que estos
últimos meses han sido duros ahora casi
una semana si voy a ser osada walkout
ocho meses de bloqueo incluyendo tres de
crisis política
durante los cuales la simbólica pareja
ha concedido muchas entrevistas a medios
de comunicación griegos e
internacionales a cuantos periodistas
recibieron este verano efecto shock a lo
que luego don diego no o yo diría que
mínimo 50 claro es un poco tedioso pero
lo hago me siento aquí y responda a las
entrevistas por una razón sus lados para
que la gente entienda que nada se
interpone entre los ciudadanos de
kastelórizo y los de cas y rectora
absolutamente nada sin embargo hace tres
días la emisión de este reportaje de la
televisión pública alemana en turco
atrajo la atención del otro lado del mar
el día de nuestro rodaje grigol recibió
una advertencia en el contexto actual
sus amigos turcos le aconsejan que no
vuelva a aparecer en televisión vive
mucho más hijos y su esposa sienten que
su historia se les escapa y se niegan a
convertirse en un símbolo político
así que frente a nuestra cámara chicos
aparece solo en la cocina esta es la
oportunidad de observar las muy
concretas consecuencias de la ruptura de
los vínculos entre los dos puertos
vecinos con todas estas verduras de aquí
vienen de rodas normalmente las
compramos en casa es mucho más fácil 25
minutos en barco
rodas está cinco horas en ferry y una
vez que llegan ya están marchitas
al frente
en el mercado de cash ya no saben qué
hacer para que vuelvan los turistas y
los vecinos griegos financieramente es
una gran pérdida la gente de kastelórizo
venía a hacer sus compras en grupo
incluso su tendero venía a todos los
isleños se ven privados de su fuente de
suministro de productos frescos pero
también de medicinas médicos materiales
de construcción y los turcos de calle se
quedan sin una clientela con poder
adquisitivo europeo una pérdida para
ambos lados sin salida clara
durante años verdad ha estado trabajando
para reunir a las dos comunidades es el
expresidente del club de fútbol juvenil
casi hace 20 años creó un campeonato
anual entre la ciudad turca y la isla
griega
[Música]
era increíble en el partido de vuelta a
los niños turcos corrieron hacia las
rocas bajo el faro mientras los niños
griegos llegaban en el barco aunque
apenas se conocían gritaban sus nombres
en griego y los niños griegos gritaban
los nombres de los niños turcos
nuestro objetivo era hacer eso todos los
años pero por la política por la
municipalidad hubo una ruptura en
nuestras relaciones seguimos dando las
noticias por supuesto pero nunca
hablamos de política la amistad
es más fuerte que la política el balance
las normas
pero no fue para hablar de fútbol que
era no citó en este anfiteatro griego
que data del siglo antes de cristo su
verdadera profesión es la de historiador
ha dedicado su investigación a la
historia de las dos comunidades que
están intrínsecamente ligadas a los
griegos vivían en anatolia antes de la
llegada a los turcos históricamente los
griegos son los habitantes de esta
región hasta el comienzo de la primera
guerra mundial 2000 griegos aún vivían
en casas y las aldeas costeras de los
alrededores
el comercio estaba en manos de griegos
armenios y judíos como ésta era una
ciudad portuaria ellos eran los que
comerciaban a clic sillares tomares
y cuántos turcos había en la isla en la
isla de kastelorizo había unos 150
turcos cuales en su mayoría funcionarios
aduaneros policías móviles o imanes
vivían allí por su trabajo
recalde derechos de giants o la biblia
de kastelórizo vivió como una isla
dividida entre potencias a lo largo del
siglo 20 un rico puerto bajo la
autoridad otomano en 1915 fue tomada por
francia bajo los bombardeos otomanos
kastelorizo se convirtió en chad tojos
compuesto avanzado hacia el levante y el
imperio colonial francés en 1921 francia
le cede la isla a italia y se vuelven
castell rosso bajo la era fascista en
1947 después de una breve ocupación
inglesa kastelorizo es anexada a grecia
por el tratado de parís que prevé la
desmilitarización de todas las islas del
dodecaneso en circunstancias normales
el capitán de taxi barco le gusta
mostrarles a los turistas
esta historia de plaza fuerte este
patrimonio estratégico
durante la guerra los italianos
descargaban sus armas aquí ya sea van
hasta arriba usando este viejo camino
construido por los franceses
la frontera está justo a este lado está
turquía del otro está kastelorizo y ahí
está la isla destruir esta sabrosa nos
lleva alrededor de un gran peñasco en el
sur de la isla incluso más cerca de la
costa turca un peñasco aparentemente
desierto es una isla militarizada sólo
el ejército está autorizado a ir hacia
se dice que hay cámaras escondidas en
las piedras
le pedí al ejército permiso para hacer
el tour dijeron que sólo podíamos
quedarnos en el mar y grabar desde lejos
los pescadores son los únicos que no
necesitan permiso para colocar sus
líneas alrededor de la isla
ubicación los peces pican
a bordo de le mans
morton altura en pocos meses su capitán
único
se ha vuelto tan bueno como lo es
pescando
ese es un barco griego
hay más buques de guerra especialmente
hace dos meses había muchos porque
estaban buscando gas en la costa
porque piensa de gas
es mejor que no haya nada
porque si no hay nada estaremos bien
dondequiera que haya gas petróleo hay
grandes problemas
todo el mundo quiere ya sabes
por segunda vez en tres meses un buque
de exploración sísmica turco está de
vuelta al sur de kastelórizo en la zona
económica exclusiva reclamada por grecia
el alcalde adjunto supo de esto esta
mañana a través de la publicación de un
af ex un télex de navegación emitido por
las autoridades marítimas
recibimos access todos los días
y los barcos turcos se acercan cada vez
más a nuestra isla
y eso nos pone nerviosos y estamos
cansados de este acoso
pero sepan que ahora tenemos los medios
para proteger la isla y defendernos
ha aumentado la presencia militar en la
isla
y si hay más hay más interés
por eso digo que podemos permitirnos
sentirnos seguros pero no puedo decirles
más la militarización de la isla
denunciado por turquía por ir en contra
de un acuerdo firmado en 1947 entre los
dos países sigue siendo un tabú aquí se
percibe como una necesidad porque el
apoyo europeo es demasiado incierto
emborronado que campeona en turín héctor
esquema crónico al venir a ayudarnos
nadie más lo ha hecho que los macro
bonitos problemas antes de apagar la
cámara stratus quiere contarnos una
anécdota
ya las pócimas les voy a contar algo me
acaban de llamar de tesalónica from ata
nomás nos enviaron un cargamento de
pintura para que podamos arreglar
nuestras banderas griegas en los
peñascos entonces pueden enviar más
drones está listo sí
unas pocas latas de pintura frente a las
ambiciones del presidente turco
al igual que los habitantes de la isla
quieren mostrar sus pacíficas
intenciones
si hubo empresas que claro que debemos
rezar por grecia pero grecia es europa
como la cala al lápiz evo de sí mismo y
europa fue creada para que hubiera paz y
no se dejen a fuego eficaz no sólo
dentro de sus fronteras sino también con
sus países vecinos así que si yo no sé
qué dice eso se me partieron esa cara de
mellitus que viene acá son hay esperanza
[Música]
a 150 km de distancia en las aguas que
reclama grecia el buque de la
exploración sísmica por un rey sigue
buscando gas bajo el suelo del mar
mediterráneo
hasta aquí esta emisión de reporteros en
france 24 recuerde que se le gustó este
reportaje puede ver nuevamente a través
de nuestra página web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]